china lleva varios años fortaleciendo su
presencia en América Central
Especialmente con proyectos de
infraestructura y donaciones de muestras
de buena voluntad y de amistad con los
latinos Cómo se beneficia de una buena
relación el gigante asiático y qué
supone esto para las potencias
occidentales vamos a conversar sobre
este tema de la mano de Jorge heine
quien es el profesor de relaciones
internacionales de la Universidad de
Boston y también es ex embajador desde
chile en China en India y en Sudáfrica
bienvenido Jorge Gracias por estar en
directo a américa qué tal Muy buenos
días Gusto compartir contigo Igualmente
Jorge hablemos sobre lo que ofrece china
a Centroamérica versus esa conflictiva
relación que existe en la región o con
Estados Unidos que gira alrededor por
ejemplo del fenómeno de la migración y
de una fallida política de lucha contra
las drogas china viene a ofrecer un
panorama distinto
Jorge me escucha el audio Le repito la
pregunta Qué ofrece china a
Centroamérica versus la relación de la
región con Estados Unidos que ha girado
en las últimas décadas en torno a una
política fallida de lucha contra las
drogas y a la migración ilegal hacia
Norteamérica
Sí yo creo que es importante poner esto
en perspectiva Honduras es de los países
más pobres No solo de Centroamérica sino
que también de América Latina en su
conjunto y Acá hay que ver que el
comercio con China de Honduras Aunque
hasta ahora no tienen relaciones
diplomáticas ha aumentado un 67% en el
último año llegando una cifra de mil
seiscientos millones de dólares por otra
parte el comercio con Taiwán de Honduras
solo llega a los doscientos millones de
dólares entonces Acá hay un factor
económico muy significativo lo dicho la
propia presidenta Xiomara Castro que ha
señalado que este cambio en las
relaciones diplomáticas son duras No se
hace por razones ideológicas sino que se
hace por razones económicas lo que China
la puede ofrecer a Honduras es mucho más
que lo que le puede ofrecer Taiwán
incluso nuestro corresponsal decía ayer
en un reporte sobre la noticia de
Xiomara Castro que es casi un suicidio
no aceptar tener una relación con china
en este momento y cambiarla por Taiwán
lo que deja Taiwán muy mal parado pero
este es un trabajo que ha venido
haciendo china en la última década en la
región latinoamericana teniendo una
mayor inserción en los mercados y una
mayor participación en los megaproyectos
de la región Cómo se ha visto ese cambio
con la entrada del gigante asiático
Bueno yo creo que el caso de
Centroamérica y el Caribe en particular
cabe subrayar que desde el año 2017 son
cuatro los países que han roto
relaciones con Taiwán y han establecido
relaciones diplomáticas con china
estamos hablando de Panamá República
Dominicana El Salvador y Nicaragua de
manera que Honduras sería el quinto país
en sumarse a este a este grupo y en este
momento en Centroamérica solo quedan
Belice y Guatemala como los únicos
países que mantendrían relaciones
diplomáticas con
con Taiwán en el Caribe Está también
Haití San Vicente Santa Lucía
y en Sudamérica queda Paraguay ahora acá
hay una pregunta bien interesante que es
la siguiente qué país en las Américas va
a querer ser el último en establecer
relaciones diplomáticas con china china
es un país con una larga memoria
histórica mi país chile se ha
beneficiado de haber sido el primer país
en Sudamérica en establecer relaciones
diplomáticas con china por allá por el
año 1970 entonces Yo me pregunto Quién
quiere arriesgarse a ser el último país
en las Américas en establecer relaciones
diplomáticas con china Yo creo que es
algo a tener presente
y Cómo afecta esto a Estados Unidos que
también ha mostrado una fuerte presencia
bajo el gobierno de Joe biden o más bien
Un fuerte deseo de mejorar las
relaciones recordemos que al inicio de
este año hubo varias visitas a varios
países latinoamericanos se han hecho más
comunes las giras y los anuncios de
apoyos En financiación cuál es la
competencia ahí entre Estados Unidos y
China
sí obviamente Estados Unidos esto no le
cae bien
la pregunta es sin embargo Hasta qué
punto los países
Centroamericanos van a estar en
condiciones de seguir negando su sus
relaciones diplomáticas con la segunda
mayor Economía del mundo que es que es
china yo creo que acá la versión tiene
que ser una visión pragmática Esto no se
hace como ha dicho la presidenta Castro
por razones ideológicas esto es un tema
estrictamente económico Honduras repito
es un país muy pobre con series
dificultades con problemas de deuda
Obviamente el comercio con china es
mucho más significativo que con Taiwán
Hay posibilidades de inversión todo tipo
de proyecto en ese sentido yo creo que
Estados Unidos debe ver esto como una
situación en la cual Honduras está
haciendo lo que corresponde el propio
Estados Unidos tiene relaciones
diplomáticas con china no las tiene con
Taiwán de manera que yo creo que es muy
difícil insistir en una política es que
ya básicamente está obsoleta Claro sin
embargo quisiera preguntarle por el
aspecto geopolítico porque en esta
competencia de China de Estados Unidos
que sea además profundizado ahora con
cuando el gigante es ético empieza a
asumir posición frente a la guerra en
Ucrania pues hay que evaluar esos
esfuerzos que china ha hecho por
aumentar su presencia en América Latina
y lo que nos ocupa en esta entrevista en
Centroamérica Usted cree que estos
esfuerzos que ha invertido china en la
región Durante los últimos años empiezan
a dar fruto
por supuesto pero yo creo que es
importante acá tener presente lo
siguiente Ah esto no no debe plantearse
como una especie de esfuerzo unilateral
por parte de China por por ponerlo de
alguna manera por penetrar Centroamérica
hay que tener presente esto es un
esfuerzo bilateral son los países
Centroamericanos también los que tienen
interés en establecer relaciones
diplomáticas con china Por las razones
de beneficio económico que Yo señalaba
anteriormente es más ha habido casos
de países Centroamericanos que estaban
interesados en establecer relaciones
diplomáticas con China antes del año
y China le dijo No vamos a esperar un
poco porque las condiciones todavía no
están dadas de manera que esto es un
esfuerzo conjunto de los países
centroamericanos y de China Yo
subrayaría también otro fenómeno también
interesante y es que Panamá que fue el
primero en la región en establecer
relaciones con china por allá por el año
2017 en este momento está negociando un
tratado de libre comercio con china que
es algo que habrá que seguir de cerca
Porque también le Abre buenas
posibilidades a Panamá
Bueno vamos a poner un ejemplo al final
del año 2021 el presidente de El
Salvador nayib bukele anunció el inicio
de una construcción de un estadio de
fútbol con fondos de cooperación no
reembolsables de China entonces aquí
claro usted lo está diciendo y es que
tiene que ser un esfuerzo bilateral para
hallar estos encuentros económicos que
espera el gobierno de chimpín a cambio
de esta y otras muestras de amistad con
los pueblos latinoamericanos porque la
presencia ha sido a través de
participación en mega proyectos pero
también a través de donaciones
correcto bueno acá yo creo que hay dos
modelos un modelo es alguna medida que
siguió Costa Rica el que el que está el
que siguió El Salvador que es pedir algo
muy concreto a cambio la conducción de
un estadio lo que yo he llamado
diplomacia de estadios es algo bastante
bastante común Pero hay otro modelo que
es el modelo que siguió Panamá Panamá
dijo no nosotros No pedimos nada
nosotros lo que queremos es tener una
relación diplomática normal y una
relación económica normal y se podría
argumentar que el modelo de Panamá ha
resultado bastante más fructífero en
Panamá ha firmado numerosos acuerdos a
varios grandes proyectos chinos en curso
en Panamá porque lo hizo sin pedir nada
a cambio yo creo que son dos enfoques
distintos Habría que ver exactamente lo
que ha negociado Honduras lo que va a
negociar Honduras con china pero me
parece que el enfoque no debe ser pedir
estadios el enfoque debe ser Buscar una
relación madura avanzada entre países
soberanos con los beneficios para ambas
partes pero bueno para que eso pase
Tendremos que ver más años y más
desarrollo en estas relaciones
comerciales ahora para volver al tiempo
presente Usted cree que estos
movimientos recientes van a generar más
tensiones Taiwán China y por lo tanto
más tensiones Estados Unidos China
a ver yo creo que en este momento Taiwán
lo que tiene son 13 países que tienen si
sacamos a Honduras Trece países que
tienen relaciones diplomáticas con
Taiwán obviamente Este es tu número que
va a seguir disminuyendo con el correr
del tiempo de manera que la apuesta
insistir por mantener
estas relaciones es una apuesta
perdedora no es una apuesta de gran
futuro yo creo que los países de la
región deben darse cuenta de eso y no
seguir insistiendo en un enfoque que a
mí me parece que tiene poca relación con
la realidad de nuestro tiempo yo
quisiera subrayar También acá otro
elemento que es muy interesante
precisamente que tiene que ver con esta
extensión geopolíticas y es que nuestro
país es en Centroamérica y también en
Sudamérica se ven un poco entre la
espada y la pared entre las presiones
por un lado de Washington y de Beijing
para alinearse con uno o con otro
es lo que estamos viendo cada vez más y
lo vemos también en relación a la guerra
en Ucrania es que los países
latinoamericanos están diciendo nosotros
optamos por una posición de no
alineamiento no nos queremos alinear con
uno o con otro y Honduras dice nosotros
creemos tener muy buenas relaciones con
Estados Unidos que la que siempre hemos
tenido pero también queremos tener
buenas relaciones con China y eso es lo
que estamos viendo cada vez más como el
patrón establecido